The world's tiniest prison is located on Sark
Island of the United Kingdom. It was built
in 1856 and is still used for overnight stays,
but it can house only two inmates.
What The FAK: The facts and knowledge on Prisons.
San Pedro Prison is the biggest in Bolivia
and is home to about 1,500 inmates. But beyond
the thick wall and security gates, any resemblance
to a normal jail disappears. There are children
playing, markets, hairdressers, and even a
hotel; but no guards, uniforms, or metal bars.
Inmates have to pay their way while inside,
including paying for the cell that they live
in. The police do not go inside or interfere
as inmates are expected to resolve their own
problems through elected representatives.
Leoben Minimum Security Prison in Austria
looks more like a high-end apartment complex
than a prison. It has an abundant amount of
natural light, a court-yard, and barred off
balconies. And, the average prisoner gets
their own kitchenette, comfortable furniture,
and a TV. Inmates can also enjoy a game of
tennis, indoor soccer, a weight room, or romantic
conjugal visit suites.
At the other end of the prison spectrum is
the US Penitentiary, Administrative Maximum
Facility, or ADX, located in Florence, Co.
It was constructed in response to several
security breaches and correctional officer
injuries at other maximum security prisons.
ADX is best known for housing inmates who
have been deemed too dangerous, too high-profile,
or too great a national security risk such
as leaders of violent gangs, domestic and
foreign terrorists, and inmates at high escape-risk.
Cells have a desk, a stool, and a bed which
are almost entirely made out of concrete,
as well as a toilet that shuts itself off
if blocked, and a shower where the water runs
on a timer to prevent flooding.
.
Alcatraz is one of the most well known prisons
in the world. It was a maximum high security
federal prison located on Alcatraz Island
in the San Francisco bay, and operated from
1934-1963. It was designed to hold prisoners
who continually caused trouble at other federal
prisons, and held some of the most hardened
criminals in Americas history including Al
Capone and George "Machine Gun" Kelly. It
was believed to be inescapable and America's
strongest prison. A total of 36 prisoners
made 14 escape attempts during its 29 years
of operation, but it was closed march 21st,
1963 due to high maintenance costs and a poor
reputation.
Aranjuez Prison in Spain is the only one in
the world to house two-parent inmate families.
The units come with cribs, Disney characters
on the walls, and have access to a playground.
When the children turn 3 they have to leave
the prison to be looked after by family. They're
still debating on the success of the program
and the health of the children, so there are
no plans to expand the program.
The Fortezza Medicea Restaurant opened in
2006 to the public as an alternative dining
experience. A 20-person team of inmates, made
up of robbers and convicted murderers, prepare
and serve 120 covers for diners who have undergone
strict security and background checks. All
guests are served with plastic plates and
cutlery inside of this prison restaurant.
Bastoy Minimum Security Prison is located
on the small, scenic Bastoy Island, about
an hour from Oslo, Norway. The prison is organized
as a small, local community with about 80
buildings, roads, beach zones, a football
field, and agricultural land. The farming
is ecological, the prison handles most of
their own trash, and there is a constant focus
on minimizing CO2 emissions, and this progressive
prison has been criticized by some for being
more like a summer camp than a correctional
facility.
One weekend in April, and every sunday in
October, Louisiana is home to the Angola Prison
Rodeo. Thousands enter the prison complex
to see the show that started in 1965. Black
and white striped cowboys compete in events
like the "convict poker", "wild cow milking",
and bull riding. You can hear inmate bands
playing, eat food made from old family recipes,
and even buy arts and crafts made by the prisoners
themselves.
Cebu Prison in the Philippines is famous for
its dancing inmates. It was an evolution of
the exercise program that turned into an internet
sensation. 1,500 prisoners are able to contribute
to the performances, and they do so at charitable
and cultural events, as well as live performances,
after which spectators can have their pictures
taken with the inmates.
Built in 1876 Spandau Prison was notable for
housing many Nazi war criminals after World
War 2. It was decided that the building should
come down to prevent a Nazi shrine from being
built. They chose 1987 because that is when
the prison's last inmate finally died at the
age of 93, and he'd been the only inmate since
1966. Rudolf Hess was guarded on a rotation
for those 21 years by allied guards of Americans,
French, Brits, and even Soviets because he'd
been sentenced to spend his life in prison,
and they wanted to make sure that he did...
I'm gonna leave you with this guy. He escaped
high security prisons twice. Who is he, and
what was his escape method of choice?
Before we go here's last video's winner. Be
sure to subscribe for more Vsauce2 and, as
always, thanks for watching.